okay
so this question comes from
donald hoffman
he wants to know
is space-time an aspect of fundamental
reality
and also can there be a theory of
everything so you can tackle whichever
one you want and we'll start as usual
with yosha
uh no it's not the
obvious giveaway is that the collapse of
the waveform marks a point in your past
beyond which you cannot obtain a model
of events happening in time and space it
in a pinpointed fashion
that is one of the answers another one
is that
the traditional notion of time and space
requires a temporal and spatial
continuum
and the temple and spatial continuum
would require that you have basically an
infinite granularity
of things that are happening which if
you turn this into a constructive
language means that you would have to
process infinite amounts of information
in a finite number of steps and this
leads in contradictions in the
definition of language which means we
cannot properly define these terms
without running into contradictions it's
also not necessary to do this so we can
create constructs that allow us to model
the function of the universe to a very
low level without going to continuity so
i don't think that space time itself
exists but it is an apparent thing that
happens at a certain level of course
graining
there and there are properties uh of
space-time this which means the
regularity and flatness and so on that
are probably required for
having us in it so basically for an
evolution you need to have a region of
uh of the universe where you can apply
the things that you learn in one corner
uh in another corner
and
your control actually works over time
spans and over space
so uh
you there is a reason why the universe
around us looks as if it was happening
in nearly continuous space
and within nearly continuous time
john
um so i guess um
donald's question
um
i i guess i would want to talk to him
about a fundamental ontology do i think
that time and space are the ultimate
our ultimate reality uh no i i don't
think so i think i heard yoshi saying
something similar to that um
that doesn't by the way mean that i
think they're an illusion and i don't
think yoshi was saying that either
i think we have to be very careful about
when we're talking about these kinds of
levels
because
our
it's not the case and this is going to
go towards my answer the second thing
it's not the case that we can find all
the explanations we want at any
particular level
um
and
there's lots of arguments for this but
um i don't think there's one level from
which all the explanations
uh can be generated
and so in that sense if what you mean by
a theory of everything is a theory in
which all explanations are reduced
to i don't know quantum mechanic
explanations and even if those are
explanations it's questionable um i i
don't see that as a viable project
so
do i think time and space are ultimate
reality no
i don't think that means they're an
illusion
and i think we should talk about
um
there being something like
a con
a levels uh
of of reality
um
i think that
things not only emerge
out of the quantum base
um they are also constrained
uh by uh you know
law-like features of reality which
aren't properly talked about as being in
time and space
um
um so like
i don't know what it would mean to say
like that two plus two equals four is
that temporal spatial that makes no
sense
um even something like equals mc squared
it doesn't make sense to talk about it
being
here or there or starting then or there
um and of course there's lots of other
entities like this so
we have emergence up out of something
like yoshi was talking about a
non-temporal spatial probability realm
and we also have higher order
constraints
um
that
also don't seem to be spatial temporal
and i think
i think of time and space as caught
between that emergence and their
emanation i think part of what we're
doing
when we're playing with quantum
mechanics and relativity
relativistic stuff and trying to
reconcile them not this is not a perfect
mapping but we're trying to get clear
about how those levels uh
are appropriately real together
um
and so
that would be my answer to both
questions i don't think they're
ultimately real i don't think that says
they're an illusion um and i don't think
there is a theory of everything because
i don't think if by theory of everything
you mean i'm gonna pick one level and
that's the level at which i will be able
to explain everything i mean
joshua for example uh and he's perfectly
legitimate for him doing this is not a
criticism he picks a computational level
right and right and that's the level
from which he works
but that doesn't mean that like
like he thinks uh
he
i don't think he should respond to this
criticism which i take to be a
pseudo-criticism oh but the
computational is ultimately just
right uh thermodynamic or something like
that um and
i know thermodynamics is a way to talk
about computation it's it's the rather
very round
so and in some sense there uh you know
that has a glass panel maybe
it's a famous book that he has written
in which he describes uh somewhat
metaphorically a world in which uh
people do science and philosophy by
playing a certain game with glass beats
yes and this game is never completely
explained how it works right yeah yeah
so but you you are free to uh project
whatever you want and this so you can
imagine it something like an extremely
complicated abacus in which you are
shifting these glass speeds around
according to very intricate rules and it
allows you to
to reason about the world in some kind
of automatic fashion
and you're playing it against each other
but you are playing it according to
rules and the individual that is playing
it is not crucial for this game at all
it's the rules of the game itself
and so i think what happened this
computation is that we discovered a
glass pattern sphere
and we discovered the equivalence of all
glass pattern spiels that can possibly
be constructed
and whenever we found something new to
uh express ideas we also discovered for
this new thing to express ideas that it
can be mapped to a glass bearing sphere
and now there is this big question um
can there be a glass filled spiel of
everything which means could the
universe exist within a glass pattern
sphere
and uh from where i stand it seems to be
that the answer is yes but i don't know
this uh so i cannot know this before i
haven't succeeded in doing so but in
some sense that's the game that i'm
playing here
it's a good book i love herman hessa i
recommend the book um
um yeah i guess i i tend to uh
i tend to be a little bit more
pragmatic in the philosophical sense
about uh scientific explanations uh
meant that they're always bound to
my interests my concerns the concerns of
my group
and again you've said things that are
not inconsistent with that um
so
well i don't know if there's anything
more to say i mean that could launch us
into another long discussion perhaps
but i think i've tried to answer the
question
i don't think they're ultimately real i
think they are intermediate literally
real
right in some ways um as i've tried to
say
um
that doesn't mean they're an illusion
uh and i
i i'm suspicious of
uh grand reductive explanations
maybe more suspicious than yosha uh
because i've watched them fail in the
history
of science and the history of philosophy
um
i think more
and it's unclear whether or not what
yoshi's
proposing does a reduction or does what
i'm now going to talk about what i see
now
um is kind of reciprocal reciprocal
reconstruction between these various
levels of discourse
i see the ai people
changing the minds of the
neuroscientists and vice versa
and the ai people changing the minds of
the psychologists and vice versa it's
not that anyone any one person claims uh
to have this um and i don't know if the
glass speed game would be a claim of
reduction to itself
or a game in which we can really
facilitate uh the most optimal kind of
reciprocal reconstruction between our
various ontologies and strategies of
measuring and explaining the world
so that's how i would answer that